we have to start today with yet another
defeat or failure for the so-called
anti-woke movement it's really important
to understand that all of these folks in
the current American right wing who
insists that America is embroiled in a
culture War around which apparently the
survival of the country depends which I
don't believe for a second one of the
things that they will rarely if ever
admit is that the war is extraordinarily
one-sided in the sense that it is the
retrograde right wing that has chosen to
fight these battles and it has been the
left having no choice but to react and
say hey the things you're asking for
don't make sense the battles you're
choosing to fight are battles that we
now have to get involved in not because
we want to but because you are trying to
discriminate and under the law create
multiple tiers of people and so on and
so forth but
they are suffering defeat after defeat I
told you earlier this week that the
Tennessee anti-drag bill has been
blocked it does appear to violate the
First Amendment we talked about a new
Gallup study that finds that support for
gay marriage is as high as ever in the
United States the Utah book ban has
backfired and actually led to the Bible
being banned and even the Book of Mormon
is now being looked at to say hey wait a
second if we're Banning sexual and
violent content don't these books also
have to be banned so it has been failure
after failure after failure and we now
have yet another defeat a federal judge
has blocked Florida's ban on gender
affirming care for minors in a narrow
ruling and has stated gender identity is
real the Associated Press reports saying
gender identity is real
a federal judge temporarily blocked
portions of a new Florida law that bans
trans miners from receiving puberty
blockers ruling Tuesday that the state
has no rational basis for denying
patients treatment they have many
irrational bases but no rational basis
this is a preliminary injunction from
Judge Robert Hinkle who says three trans
kids can continue receiving treatment
the lawsuit challenges the law that
Governor Ron DeSantis signed the same
week he announced a run for president
Hinkle said the elephant in the room
should be noted at the outset gender
identity is real the record makes this
clear despite the defense admissions
there are those who believe that
cisgender individuals properly adhere to
their natal sex and that trans
individuals have inappropriately chosen
a contrary gender identity male or
female just as one might choose whether
to read Shakespeare or Grisham uh this
is
extraordinarily important now I want to
we we've talked about so many different
aspects of this and of course this is
only a preliminary injunction or as Mike
pillow says of eliminary adjunction uh
regardless of how you say it this is
only a preliminary injunction and it's
possible that the law may be upheld I
want to talk about the religious
component here with many of these issues
because when we talk about the abortion
bans the attempts to ban gay marriage
the attempts to justify discrimination
on the basis of sexual orientation or
gender identity often there are
religious justifications that are cited
now we could talk about how these
anti-woke positions aren't actually the
most popular positions we could there's
all sorts of things we could talk about
but because we've done that already
let me briefly address the religious
component to this we often see defenses
or justifications for these laws on
religious grounds and when I say
religious grounds I'm talking about
Christianity and when I say Christianity
I'm mostly talking about Evangelical
Christianity that those are that's the
strong religious movement in this
country that is pushing most of this
anti-woke stuff
I am wondering whether it would be
interesting to fight some of these laws
on the basis that they value that they
violate the religious beliefs of others
I'll give you an example according to
Jewish law
human life begins at Birth not at
conception it begins at the first breath
the majority of foundational Jewish
texts say a fetus does not attain
personhood until birth so Judaism does
not consider that life begins at
conception but rather at the moment of
the lit of delivery could I or any other
Jewish person Sue saying that
anti-abortion bills violate their
religious beliefs this has been
mentioned before and it would be an
extraordinarily interesting path to
approach uh to take to approach fighting
some of these laws now similarly we can
look at gender identity in many Jewish
belief systems
uh
it is recognized that there are six
distinct genders including male female
and intersex identities Reform Judaism
advocates for transgender Justice
affirms the value of all people
regardless of gender identity now of
course you could find Orthodox Judaism
which would have a different view but is
there not an argument to be made
that these anti-trans laws of all kinds
whether it comes to gender affirming
care or whether it comes to pronouns or
whether it comes to bathrooms or
whatever the case may be violates the
religious beliefs and practices of many
Jewish movements groups of Jews sects
maybe they would be called I think that
there is something here and I know it's
been mentioned in passing by some rabbis
if they are going to go the religious
Direction with this I would like to
explore fighting them on the same
grounds it's not going to be me
necessarily as a non-religious person I
consider myself you know culturally
ethnically and culinarily Jewish for
lack of a better term uh but this really
should be looked at and the if we want
to find a silver lining in this entire
cultural war that the right has
Unleashed upon the country it's that
they don't actually seem to have the
majority of the country on their side
and also that they don't see seem to
have the law on their side when it comes
to what they're pushing